how much have you traveled to watch
wrestling uh i mean a middle amount i'm
going to chicago this weekend to go see
wrestling what's fun about it is then
oftentimes i get like free tickets and
stuff so then it makes it feel real fun
yeah but um i had always since i was a
little kid i was like i want to go to
japan i want to go to the tokyo dome and
i want to watch wrestling and it was
great and i tell you the part that i
love the most that i did not expect is
that they let you bring your own food in
at these
ones in tokyo america
that's crazy if you wanted to bring a
full ass picnic basket and a bad gas and
just a full plant you could do that wow
it's wild wow did you watch the david
arquette documentary i did yeah what'd
you think of that i thought it was great
yeah he had um
the guy that [ __ ] sliced it nick
was on his podcast oh yeah he came to my
house did my podcast my wife was
disturbed
he's an interesting guy man interesting
he looks he's robbed the bank he looks
like he's robbed a bank yeah my wife was
like
why did you let this guy in
[Laughter]
i didn't yeah what was the other i tried
oh yeah one phrase that he had
on your show was he goes
uh i don't care man if someone's [ __ ]
with you because it sounds [ __ ] with
me i'm gonna fight him that's just such
a crazy mentality yeah it really is like
just like he has no walk away yeah yeah
yeah
it's
like parking spaces i just like
immediately went to like small innocuous
things he's like nah like it's going
down
yeah have you had a chance to brush
shoulders with david like after that
whole thing or
um no i don't think i've ever met him in
person i've talked to him online
um talked to twitter or whatever friends
with some of his friends but um i've
never met him in person but i think it's
super cool to like
kind of have this mission that he had
where he came into wrestling like 20
years ago and they made him the champion
and everybody hated him and it like
affected him so much that he was like
you know what i'm just gonna wrestle for
real and earn it and do it my way and do
it an independent way and gain the
wrestler's respects and he does it and
it's pretty cool i mean i wouldn't want
to have gotten stabbed in the neck like
yeah i would have avoided it yeah that
was a little hardcore
yeah getting his neck cut open a little
bit hey man
that's the grind
that's what we thought we were getting
into when we went to santino bro yeah
really all right they're going to hack
us open man yeah that's crazy the open
mics of wrestling are so much more
violent yeah than [ __ ] stand up open
mics yeah and you'd be like wow like
yeah i used to like come here and bomb
for like three minutes but nobody cut me
open yeah yeah in front of 12 people you
know no disrespect
[Laughter]
no i mean that that means you love it
you know yeah yeah some will say too
much
[Laughter]
are you are you are you working on much
stand up these days or yeah i've been on
tour a bit just kind of wrapped up this
tour to kind of um
just get my hour together and stuff um
um so now i'm just kind of doing
little spot dates here and there i'm
gonna be at like the brea improv
september 8th and then i'm going
it looks like i'm going near miami and
then some other places but for the most
part i'm trying to um
stay home with the baby yeah as i can
something that uh and i guess no i did
that with my first son too because i
hadn't even started comedy then yeah so
it's just something i like to do when
the because it goes so quick so i'm
trying to stay home with him as much as
i can and try to write and try to act
and try to uh host stuff i just like
doing different stuff i don't ever want
to be forced
down any particular
lane and like end up you know
in some hotel when i'm 60 and some doing
some gig i don't want to do i don't want
that life yeah what's like exciting you
the most right now
thank you for asking me
um right now i mean i'm just pitching a
project i'm really excited about with um
with this character dan hausen and um
it's really been fun and interesting
something it's been you know some people
turn it down some people seem real
interested so we'll see how it works out
and um i like i just like writing and
creating stuff for other people and
helping myself out learn new things
um i like my podcast my wrestling
podcast i like doing that a lot right
now
uh and then i like
the show loot that i'm on because i get
to act with my rudolph yeah how was that
it's amazing yeah
and is it crazy working with her it's so
cool it's like i imagine it's like you
know working with someone like lucille
ball or like um i mean that's what matt
exactly what i mean it's like because
like she's such a legend to me and she's
such a boss and like
really kind and really um
open to letting you pitch things and
talk about things and like just really
weird things like i remember just this
small little thing where there was this
line
where they were like
it says something i don't even remember
the line exactly but it said something
that i was gonna try to do something and
i just was casually talking to her and i
go like i don't like the word try and
comedy because like try is in the middle
and the comedy to me is either you made
a decision or you didn't interesting and
then she was like you're right and she's
like just take it out and i was like oh
okay wow like i was just i was just
talking yeah yeah and for her to be like
no i get that you're right about that
take the try out it is better if you
just do or do not yes yeah that's just
how i think about comedy did she write
it
uh did she write it she wrote it she
just you know the producer on it and
we all can improvise a bit so it's real
fun in that way man i was going to say
just in your career it seems like you've
been able to just
do a lot of bucket list things
especially at this point
um
just to your point about like you know
like working with maya rudolph and then
even like all these experiences you have
wrestling do you ever get like feelings
where you're like
do you think that's what kind of
motivates you to try new things because
you always kind of want to create those
new goals and just have new things to
aim for is that not necessarily at the
front of your mind uh i mean usually the
thing i have from my mind is just i just
don't like to be bored yeah
i think um
when i was coming up i would always
read a lot of things from like pat and
oswalt and all these other comedians and
they were talked about like
how there's different worlds in comedy
and that like and and in career and then
a lot of places people use seniority
as the excuse for like why they should
be a place right like i've been doing
this 15 years i've been doing this 20
years but as we see in entertainment in
anything like you can be young you can
be whatever you if you get it together
it doesn't matter yeah you see like some
people have you know say they have 20
years in something and they've been
doing the same year 20 times yeah yeah
you know and so that has been my goal is
to have a different year every time is
that doing something i've never done
every time and sometimes like i'm
apprehensive about it because you get in
your head about like oh what my peers
are going to think you know even from
the very beginning when i was like when
they were like do you want to do trolls
or whatever and i was like ah
oh man i kind of want to focus on stand
up and be real and get like specials
like my friends and stuff and then i was
like
that's stupid like all my favorite
comedians robin williams chris rock all
these people they did these big voice
acting things and that's what i grew up
loving why wouldn't i try that and then
they were like oh you want to be on the
cooking show these bacon shows and
and i was like oh i don't know i don't
know anybody there i don't know any they
won't i'll be the only comedian there
and then i was like oh [ __ ] i'll be the
only comedian there yeah i don't have to
compete against eight nine other
comedians yeah all trying to come up
with the same joke like on at midnight
or something yeah yeah it's just i can
just be me and i'll be funny and people
will like it and it led to like you know
i just went on chopped and
cupcake wars and these bacon shows and
then like ended up hosting a whole show
and it's like i didn't
know where to leave you exactly yeah
exactly just be open i think that's such
a great phrase i've never heard that
like not having the same year 20 times i
love that yeah i'm not gonna staple that
to my forehead man i think it's also
cool as a fan
like finding out finding about out about
someone through one thing and then
learning they do all these other things
yeah
like for people that love your stand-up
that then are like wait he does oh he
does twitch too yeah yeah i'm gonna
watch him every day yeah i mean that's
the mission right now is connecting
everything like because i do get a lot
of people who only know me from one
thing another and also with the weight
loss and stuff sometimes people don't
even they're like oh you're that
comedian from that from you know from
the purple sweater and
[Laughter]
right now you know i think the twitch
and like just trying to you know stuff
like this where i'm trying to
build it together so people know like oh
the guy who does king shark and that guy
who axon lewd is the guy you can go see
on the weekend yeah you know because i'm
trying to fill these rooms yeah yeah
yeah that is the weirdest thing now
especially with the internet is when you
you could because you can do 100 things
now you have like you know all these
niche little groups and
i don't think anyone has like the the
catch-all to like bring all those people
together yet i mean remember we used to
work like as programmers i remember back
in the day
remember people used to kick around
ideas about apps with like oh what if it
took all your timelines from every app
and it merged into one app we're like
yeah that's never happening
no i did a couple of parties i think
like yeah my agency did one invested in
one of those apps
the whole thing and i was like six
months later they were like never mind
yeah
yeah no that's not happening but apple
has invested
no we were just trying to have a party
man
you